merci d'être avec nous Rémi Féraud et de
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur socialiste de Paris
on va bien sûr parler de la réforme des
retraites dont l'examen a pris fin à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était vendredi
minuit loin d'être allé jusqu'au bout en
l'article 7 n'a même pas été discuté
est-ce que la nuque a une mauvaise
stratégie
ça dépend quel groupe je crois que le
travail notamment des députés
socialistes et je pense en particulier à
particulier à Jérôme Guedj a été
extrêmement utile pour débusquer les
mensonges les imprécisions les
approximations du gouvernement notamment
sur la retraite à 1200 euros mais je
crois que la stratégie de LFI et ça
apparaît au grand jour aujourd'hui
n'était pas la bonne il fallait voter
sur l'article cette à l'Assemblée
nationale et ce n'est pas spécialement
moi qui le dise ce sont aujourd'hui
l'ensemble de ceux qui s'opposent à
cette réforme et en particulier
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
ça mérite d'être entendu je crois donc
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon le responsable
de ce qui s'est passé pour vous non
c'est d'abord le gouvernement mais
est-ce que RFI a rendu service au
gouvernement en empêchant dans un
calendrier extrêmement contraint et ça
c'est la faute du gouvernement en
empêchant que l'assemblée se prononce
sur l'article 7 oui je le crois je crois
qu'il aurait mieux valu que l'assemblée
puisse étudier l'article 7 se prononcer
et que les positions de chacune et
chacun soient claires quand on voit les
divisions chez LR quand on voit aussi
les divisions dans la majorité
présidentielle qui n'a qu'une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée ça valait le coup
d'aller au moins jusqu'à cet article 7
et ensuite si l'Assemblée nationale n'a
pas le temps n'a pas eu le temps
d'étudier vraiment ce texte ne nous
trompons pas de responsable le
responsable c'est le gouvernement qui a
choisi cette méthode et cette ce fameux
article de la Constitution 47 1 sur il y
a eu un tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
a mis un peu le feu aux poudres à
l'Assemblée jeudi soir où il a fustigé
le retrait des amendements de la part
des communistes et où il a tweeté hâte
de vous faire battre comment vous l'avez
interprété ce tweet Jean-Luc Mélenchon
fustige les députés communistes qui ont
bien fait de retirer leurs amendements
dans un seul but c'est que l'assemblée
puisse étudier l'article 7 hier il
fustige les propos des responsables de
la CGT et de la CFDT à l'évidence
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait fausse route
c'est pas nouveau depuis la rentrée
parlementaire mais là ça se voit et je
pense que chacun doit ouvrir les yeux
aussi sur quel est l'opposition efficace
utile qu'elle a été la meilleure pour
s'opposer à la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale et au sein de la
gauche Sana à l'évidence pas été les
insoumis chacun doit ouvrir les yeux
est-ce que le groupe socialiste aussi
d'en tirer les conséquences à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il faut
mettre fin au groupe inter parlementaire
de la nuque non il ne faut pas mettre
fin à cette
inter-groupe de la nups qui permet de
discuter et d'aimer de mener des combats
en commun mais ça ne doit pas être la
ligne des insoumis qui s'imposent à
l'ensemble des autres et socialistes
communistes ont été sur une stratégie
commune nous verrons bien je suis
moi-même sénateur mais je pense que cela
aura des conséquences bien sûr et en
attendant ne faisons rien qui puisse
venir abîmer davantage l'opposition le
fronde opposition à cette réforme des
retraites et justement on va parler de
la stratégie au Sénat puisque le texte
va maintenant arriver au Sénat il sera
examiné à partir de la semaine prochaine
on va faire le point sur ce que contient
ce texte avec Alex poussa
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Rémy Ferro bonjour
et Alex qu'est-ce qui ressort de ces
débats à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
que le texte a vraiment évolué combien
le texte n'a pas vraiment évolué puisque
les députés n'ont examiné que les deux
premiers articles sur les 20 articles de
cette réforme des retraites la
suppression des régimes spéciaux de
retraite a été adopté mais en revanche
l'obligation pour les entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés de publier un index
sur l'emploi des seniors a été supprimé
par l'Assemblée nationale mais malgré
cette suppression et bien le
gouvernement souhaite réintroduire cette
mesure durant le débat au Sénat et puis
sinon et bien les principales mesures de
cette réforme des retraites n'ont pas
été examinées par les députés pas de
débat sur la sur la retraite à 64 ans
sur le compte pénibilité sur la retraite
minimale à 1200 euros ou encore sur le
dispositif carrière longue mais le
Gouvernement sur ce dispositif carrière
longue à bien finalement garanti comme
le demandait le député les républicains
Aurélien Pradier que tous ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans ne
n'est pas à cotisé plus de 43 nuités
c'est à dire la durée légale de
cotisation pour partir à taux plein
comment vont se dérouler les débat au
Sénat Alex et bien les choses sérieuses
vont commencer la semaine prochaine le
mardi 28 février ce sera l'examen de la
réforme en commission le les débats dans
l'hémicycle vont commencer le jeudi 2
mars avec la discussion générale entre
le gouvernement et les groupes
politiques il y aura le dépôt
d'éventuels motions de la part de
l'opposition pour rejeter d'emblé ce
texte ou pour demander l'organisation
d'un référendum et puis à partir du
vendredi 3 mars ce sera à l'examen du
texte amendement par amendement il
devrait y avoir moins d'amendements au
Sénat qu'il y en a eu à l'Assemblée
nationale et puis les sénateurs auront
en tout jusqu'au dimanche 12 mars à
minuit pour examiner cette réforme et
ensuite que se passer et bien ensuite à
partir du 13 mars il y aura une réunion
entre 7 députés et 7 sénateurs pour se
mettre d'accord sur une version commune
de cette réforme des retraites c'est ce
qu'on appelle la commission mixte
paritaire encore en cas d’accord de
cette commission mixte paritaire et bien
ce texte commun réécrit sera soumis au
vote des assemblées et en cas de
désaccord la réforme des retraites
reviendra à l'Assemblée nationale qui
aura le dernier mot et jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars pour réexaminer ce texte
mais dans ce cas c'est en réalité le
gouvernement qui aura véritablement le
dernier mot puisqu'il pourra s'appuyer
sur la Constitution pour faire passer en
force cette réforme de retraite sans
tenir compte du vote des députés Rémy
feraux parlons du débat qui s'annonce au
Sénat quelle va être la stratégie de la
gauche sénatoriale est-ce que en tout
cas au début de l'examen vous allez par
exemple demander d'emblée le rejet de
cette réforme ou alors l'organisation
d'un référendum oui il y aura d'émotion
de procédure porter par la gauche il y
aura beaucoup d'amendements
pour à la fois pour obliger le
gouvernement à répondre sur l'ensemble
des points qui restent extrêmement
floues dans cette réforme et puis aussi
pour faire des propositions alternatives
à une réforme injuste et puis pour que
le débat est vraiment lieu et qu'il est
lieu jusqu'au bout donc bien sûr nous
utiliserons toutes les armes que nous
permettent le règlement du Sénat pour
nous opposer à cette réforme même si
nous ne sommes pas majoritaires au Sénat
beaucoup d'amendements c'est combien je
peux pas vous le dire
je ne peux pas vous dire comme l'ont
fait les insoumis ou ce sera des
centaines comme je pense qu'on sera
plutôt dans des centaines ou quelques
milliers mais je peux pas vous répondre
à la place de l'ensemble des groupes du
Sénat c'est pour les socialistes pour
les spécialistes pas totalement enfin la
stratégie ici notre volonté à la fois de
discuter l'article 7 nous opposer à
cette réforme et de tout faire dans le
respect des règles et dans le respect
des personnes aussi de tout faire pour
que le Sénat n'adopte pas cette réforme
nous le ferons donc il y aura beaucoup
d'amendements et nous serons très
présents parce que parallèlement au
mouvement social c'est évidemment ce
débat au Sénat est évidemment
extrêmement important alors vous dites
utilisez toutes les armes pour et bien
s'opposer tout faire pour que le Sénat
n'adopte pas cette réforme mais vous
souhaitez bien aller jusqu'au terme de
l'examen du texte ou une fois par passer
l'article 7 sur les 64 ans là on sera
dans l'obstruction on voulait aller
jusqu'au bout c'est vous qui qualifiez
ça d'obstruction nous voulons aller
nous voulons tout faire pour que le
Sénat n'adopte pas ce texte et si le
Sénat n'allait pas jusqu'au bout de
l'examen du texte la responsabilité
comme à l'Assemblée on reviendrait au
gouvernement puisque c'est lui qui a
choisi un calendrier extrêmement
contraint et une procédure qui limite
dans le temps la discussion
parlementaire il n'y était pas obligée
il pouvait tout à fait laisser la
discussion parlementaire se faire et
s'il n'avait pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale utiliser 49-3
n'aversons pas la responsabilité là
maintenant vous connaissez la durée
voilà ça sera du 2 au 12 mars est-ce que
vous allez tout faire pour arriver
l'article 7 ça vous nous l'avez dit mais
est-ce que vous allez aussi tout faire
pour examiner l'article 8 l'article 9
sur les carrières longues la pénibilité
où est-ce que pour vous c'est c'est
moins c'est pas grave si ça c'est pas
examiné je crois que c'est vraiment
l'article 7 qui est crucial mais croyez
bien ensuite les autres articles
derrière seront sûrement examinés mais
si nous pouvons empêcher l'adoption de
ce texte et là encore je vous le dis
dans le respect des règles et dans le
respect des personnes bien sûr je crois
que c'est très important de pouvoir le
faire faut pas inverser les
responsabilités c'est vraiment le
gouvernement qui a choisi cette
procédure vous rendez compte une réforme
aussi grave aussi essentielle qui serait
qui passerait alors que une très grande
majorité des Français sont contre
quasiment tous les actifs que
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'a pas voté
que le Sénat ne l'aurait pas voté c'est
inimaginable en réalité et je pense que
il faut que le Sénat et la gauche au
Sénat jouent son rôle donc l'objectif
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de vote de ce
texte il y en a pas eu à l'Assemblée
nationale l'objectif
donc bien sûr nous allons essayer de
faire en sorte que le Sénat ne l'adopte
pas une question sur les carrières
longues Rémy Ferro puisque c'est un
point de débat important notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés les
républicains les députés horizons sont
d'accord sur un amendement pour que tous
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler avant
21 ans ne cotise pas plus de 43 à nuités
le gouvernement a l'air au final plutôt
aussi sur cette ligne ce serait une
bonne mesure à inscrire dans cette
réforme de retraite dans le marbre de
cette réforme bien sûr mais pour le
moment le gouvernement a l'air d'eux
rien n'est dans le projet de loi ce
qu'on appelait l'amendement Pradier je
crois on ne sait pas combien il coûte
quelques centaines de millions d'euros
ou 10 milliards est-ce que ça concerne
l'ensemble des carrières longues ou
seulement ceux qui ont commencé je crois
à 16 ans ou à 21 ans enfin il y a
beaucoup et de bricolage et de flou et
aucune garantie là-dedans c'est
d'ailleurs un des points sur lesquels il
va falloir que le gouvernement réponde
enfin il y a ce point là il y a les
inégalités femmes hommes il y a la
retraite minimale à 1200 euros le
travail du Parlement c'est d'interpeller
le gouvernement et de faire émerger
aussi les faits et la vérité et
l'Assemblée nationale en particulier
grâce au députés socialiste à commencer
de le faire nous allons prendre le
relais au Sénat mais est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous pourriez voter le
fait que tous les Français qui sont dans
un dispositif carrière longue n'est pas
à travailler plus de 43 annuités ça
c'est quelque chose que vous pourriez
soutenir mais sur un ce point là oui
mais ça ne change pas l'essentiel de la
réforme
et ensuite si ça en changeait vraiment
l'esprit même on passerait d'une réforme
vu comme une réforme comptable
d'objectifs budgétaires par le
gouvernement a une réforme qui coûte
plus cher qu'elle ne rapporte ça n'a pas
de sens donc en effet sur ces questions
des carrières longues il faut absolument
obliger le gouvernement à clarifier sa
copie voir les réalités des conséquences
et puis sur un article on se prononcera
sur la réalité non pas sur des
discussions entre le gouvernement et une
partie du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale qui dans les faits n'ont
débouché sur rien de concret
sur ce rapport de force entre les
républicains et le gouvernement et ce
qu'au final vu que l'assemblée n'a pas
vraiment examiné cette réforme des
retraites que le Sénat devrait
l'examiner plutôt complètement pardon
complètement et qu'il y aura cette
fameuse réunion entre 7 députés
sénateurs parce qu'au final ce n'est pas
la version de la majorité des sénateurs
les républicains qui devraient
l'emporter dans cette réforme en tout
cas la réforme que propose le
gouvernement c'est pour l'essentiel
celle que porte les républicains ici au
Sénat depuis longtemps c'est une réforme
de droite et le gouvernement a choisi
depuis le départ de discuter avec Éric
Ciotti plutôt qu'avec les organisations
syndicales pour trouver une majorité
mais je crois que avec la force du
mouvement social et si le continue à
être aussi mobilisé pendant tout le mois
de mars le gouvernement rabat va
vraiment avoir du mal à faire passer
cette réforme et nous nous devons tout
faire ce que nous pouvons pour faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour empêcher
cette réforme de passer et justement la
grande mobilisation annoncée par les
syndicats le 7 mars tombera en pleine
examen de ce texte par le Sénat vous
pensez que ça peut faire pression sur le
parlementaires alors parce que vous
appelez faire pression mais si ça peut
éclairer un certain nombre de
parlementaires et notamment de
parlementaires de la majorité
sénatoriale de la droite sénatoriale sur
le fait que cette réforme n'est pas
seulement
inutile ou en tout cas pas urgente mais
elle est aussi extrêmement injuste
extrêmement humiliante pour beaucoup de
Français dangereuses y compris dans ce
qu'elle fracture le pays à un moment où
il a besoin et bien j'espère que cela
peut faire en effet
réfléchir un certain nombre un certain
nombre de parlementaires merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on parlera dans certains
Aurélien Pradier ce sera à suivre dans
le clavier on va voir l'actualité dans
votre région du côté de Paris puisque
pour ça on retrouve Jacques paquet
bonjour Jacques merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris et Jacques pour
commencer vous allez nous parler Dani
Delgo qui a écrit au PDG de Total pour
lui demander une gestion de sur la
facture d'électricité des écoles
absolument
vous allez nous le dire monsieur le
sénateur je crois que cette demande
s'inscrit dans un
souhait de la mère de Paris de voir les
efforts partagés finalement puisque le
conseil municipal de Paris a voté une
news de la taxe foncière de importante
de 50 % justement
provoqué par la hausse des coups de
l'énergie c'est bien ça monsieur le
sénateur est-ce que plus globalement
vous pouvez nous dire comment vous vous
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
crise de l'énergie et de l'inflation de
façon générale sur le budget de la ville
comme pour toutes les collectivités
locales l'inflation et notamment
l'inflation des coûts de l'énergie à des
conséquences budgétaires et là en
l'occurrence Anne Hidalgo a interpellé
le patron de Total énergie sur
l'augmentation de la facture pour les
caisses des écoles qui d'arrondissement
qui ont une autonomie juridique qui ont
des frais énergiques qui gèrent les
cantines parisiennes alors que nous
avons fait le choix de maintenir les
tarifs des cantines avec avec le plus
bas tarif qui est à 13 centimes et nous
avons fait ce choix mais il y a près
d'un million de coûts supplémentaires
pour l'énergie pour les caisses des
écoles qui a un contrat avec Total
énergie totale énergie qui par ailleurs
fait je crois près de 20 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices en 2022 donc Anne
Hidalgo a interpellé patron de Total
énergie pour lui demander justement mais
de participer à l'effort commun afin que
il n'y ait pas à nouveau un besoin de
rallonge budgétaire de la ville de Paris
pour subventionner les caisses des
écoles je pense que ce qui concerne là
la ville de Paris concerne des milliers
de collectivités locales en France ça
doit être prêt aussi comme un symbole un
symbole de ce qui ne va pas une hausse
des coûts de l'énergie qui pèse sur les
Français qui pèsent sur les
collectivités alors que une entreprise
comme totale énergie réalise des super
profits que le gouvernement a refusé de
taxer vous vous savez si elle avait un
retour de la part de temps elle n'en a
pas elle n'en a pas encore eu mais je
pense que vu les montants aussi annoncés
vu la situation
budgétaire des collectivités locales vu
les super profils réalisés par Total je
pense que Patrick pouyanais
va y réfléchir je l'espère en tout cas
Jacques
revenir sur le plan
de débat
absolument parce que il paraît vous
allez nous le dire monsieur le sénateur
que il serait prévu que le premier arrêt
ce plan local d'urbanisme bioclimatique
soit tu es examiné en avril mais c'est
vrai que entre les les écologistes qui
estiment que vous n'allez pas assez loin
les communistes et puis le Medef qui
estime que ce PLU est entier économique
parce qu'il risque de faire fuir les
entreprises on a l'impression que vous
êtes sur une une voie de crête et que la
recherche de l'équilibre est compliquée
comment vous quels sont vos convictions
sur ce sur ce sujet important de la
mandature
municipale ni du Conseil de Paris même
si nous écoutons bien sûr ça
participation au débat et elle est
importante ça doit être un débat citoyen
si nous trouvons un accord dans
l'ensemble de la majorité municipale sur
ce nouveau PLU qui est un élément
important pour le futur de Paris
notamment pour son adaptation à la
transition écologique et bien il
pourrait être voté au Conseil de Paris
au printemps moi j'ai entendu ce que
disait le Medef et je ne le partage pas
du tout il dit il faut construire plus
de bureau attention de ne pas mettre
trop de contraintes sur les bureaux la
réalité aujourd'hui à Paris c'est que
nous avons besoin de plus de logements
et cela il y a une unanimité là-dessus
tout en évitant de nouvelles
artificialisations des soldes tout en
adaptant la ville au changement
climatique donc c'est là dessus que nous
sommes et je n'ai pas été convaincu par
cette interpellation du Medef parce que
par ailleurs il y a toujours un
équilibre logement bureau qui doit se
faire dans la ville et qui est permis
par ce futur PLU si nous l'adoptons mais
il rééquilibrage qui sont nécessaires et
notamment aujourd'hui un rééquilibrage
en faveur du logement je crois que tous
les parisiens le savent vu aujourd'hui
l'ampleur de la crise du logement
Jacques
oui sur les avec les écologistes là ils
viennent de présenter ce weekend je
crois c'est dans les colonnes de nos
confrères du Parisien un contre-projet
sur la porte de Montreuil qui
cristallise les débats avec les
écologistes qui eux font partie de votre
majorité comment cela va se résoudre
je nous avons d'un vrai désaccord
aujourd'hui sur la porte de Montreuil
qui est un des accords assez récent
parce que dans la précédente mandature
les écologistes l'hiver au Conseil de
Paris avait voté le projet de l'apport
de Montreuil mais ces projets de la
Porte de Montreuil l'ensemble des
délibérations qui le nécessitent ont
déjà été adoptés et donc ce futur PLU ne
concerne pas le projet de la Porte de
Montreuil c'est pour ça que nos
désaccords d'aujourd'hui sur la porte de
Montreuil je pense ne mettent pas en
péril l'adoption l'adoption d'un nouveau
PLU bioclimatique sinon de toute façon
s'il n'était pas adopté nous en
resterions au PLU actuel au plan local
d'urbanisme pour être clair mais ce
serait dommage Jacques une dernière
question Grand Paris oui on reparle de
la réforme c'est une réforme serpent de
mer je sais que vous vous intéressez
monsieur le sénateur quel serait vous la
réforme administrative du Grand Paris
qu'on n'a jamais vu mais qu'on attend
toujours depuis la création de la
métropole qui montre parallèlement en
puissance quel est pour vous le Grand
Paris idéal même si en quelques secondes
ça va être difficile je peux pas vous
répondre comme ça en quelques secondes
Emmanuel Macron avait annoncé en 2017
qu'il ferait franchir un cap à la
métropole du Grand Paris n'en a rien
fait ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est
continuer de consolider la métropole et
à un moment il faudra à nouveau revoir
comment enfin passer une nouvelle étape
et je crois que cette dimension de
métropolisation reste absolument
centrale et absolument nécessaire
si on veut en effet gérer les grandes
problématiques on parlait de l'emploi du
Logement des Transports de
l'organisation de la métropole moi j'y
reste très attaché merci merci beaucoup
merci Jacques paquet d'avoir été avec
nous les autres commerciales à la
recherche d'un nouveau souffle c'est à
la Une du journal du Grand Paris cette
semaine merci beaucoup Jacques d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin on termine en
parlant des sénatoriales ce sera fin
septembre Paris fait partie des
départements renouvelables est-ce que
vous êtes candidat à votre succession en
tout cas je souhaite l'être et je
souhaite pouvoir conduire la liste des
candidats socialistes aux élections
sénatoriales en septembre prochain mais
la décision ne me revient pas ou plus
exactement pas à moi seul cette au
socialiste dans décider dans les mois
qui viennent il y a pas de raison
que ce qu'il en soit autrement ou il y a
d'autres candidats qui sont à la
candidature qui sont tête de liste qui
veulent être de liste pas à ma
connaissance je pense que Président le
groupe Paris en commun c'est le groupe
socialiste et apparenté
majoritaire dans la majorité Dany dalgo
voilà
ça crée une certaine légitimité mais pas
moto investir et puis il y a pas qu'une
tête de liste c'est une liste également
donc voilà je en tout cas je proposerai
ma candidature au socialiste parisien
pour conduire la liste aux prochaines
sénatoriales et justement sur la liste
cette liste vous souhaitez que ce soit
une liste uniquement socialiste où vous
souhaitez que ça soit une liste qui soit
élargi à toute la gauche et jusqu'où je
souhaite en tout cas qu'on puisse
proposer à nos partenaires de gauche de
la majorité municipale c'est-à-dire les
communistes et les Verts de faire une
liste ensemble c'était pas le cas aux
dernières sénatoriales mais c'était le
cas au précédentes je pense que ça
aurait du sens c'est aussi à eux de nous
dire
s'il le souhaite mais je pense que nous
pourrions avoir une liste sénatoriale
d'union vous êtes en discussion avec eux
déjà pas encore on parle de Yannick
Jadot pour être candidat au sénatorial à
Paris pour les écologistes ce sera un
bon candidat pour vous oui c'est un bon
candidat à Yannick Jadot était candidat
à l'élection présidentielle il a une
notoriété il porte il a porté le projet
des verres à l'élection présidentielle
ensuite vous comprendrez bien que c'est
pas à moi de de décider qui doit être
candidat des vers aux élections
sénatoriales donc ouais mais s'il était
candidat c'est évidemment un bon
candidat vous souhaitez des listes
unitaires alors au-delà de Paris il y a
une question qui se pose est-ce que
c'est listes unitaire à gauche doivent
accueillir des candidats de la France
insoumise quel est votre avis là-dessus
ça doit pouvoir être regardé département
par département et à Paris je ne vois
pas pourquoi il y a un élu aujourd'hui
un seul
au Conseil de Paris qui est
issu de LFI il se situe dans
l'opposition municipale je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous ferions liste commune aux
élections sénatoriales et pour ailleurs
je pense que dans la plupart des
départements ça n'est pas ce qu'il y a
de plus légitime et de plus efficace
mais il peut y avoir des exceptions
merci beaucoup Rémy fait remercier
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
on parlera de cette tribune des 131
parlementaires de la droite et du centre
c'était hier dans le Journal du Dimanche
un appel à Emmanuel Macron pour sauver
les églises la sénatrice Valérie Boyer
qui est l'une des signataires de cette
tribune sera avec nous pour en parler
mais d'abord on va cueillir notre
prochaine invité c'est Sandrine Rousseau
qui nous rejoint merci Rémi Féraud merci
à